Men do not want a woman that “needs” them
Men want a woman that *wants* them
there's a huge difference there
the woman who needs a man
expects him to provide and pay for everything
because she can't provide for herself
These are the same woman who have no job
no source of income
and they try to flip the script on men
and try to make them feel inadequate
saying they need a man who can
provide for both of them, off of one income
when it's just unrealistic for one
In this economy?!
excuse me?
they're like
“I don't need a job,
I need a man who makes enough money for the both of us”
Are you hearing yourself right now?
When a woman has her own money,
has her own job
then the man knows that she's not using him because she has nothing
when you're broke
you need a man to live, to survive
She may not even love you
she might just like what you can provide or what you do for her
Stop trying to finesse men for their money
A real woman doesn't need a man
She doesn't need you
She wants you